wir schauen auf die partyinsel der
deutschen nachdem das papier liegt der
für die deutschen ausgegangen ist auf
mallorca zumindest in der bier und in
der schinkenstraße sind jetzt auch die
briten dran auch ihnen geht's an den
party kragen denn auch in magaluf da ist
jetzt seite die party locations zu
schließen sagt zumindest die regierung
der insel eine nacht länger konnten sie
feiern
jetzt soll auch da schluss sein mit
feiern mein kollege jan landshausen ist
dort auf mallorca ist in magaluf jan ja
jetzt also nun auch schluss für die
briten in auf ihrer party meile ist
party sowieso gestorben auf der insel
mallorca
ja das sieht alles danach aus man 70
aber mir im hintergrund ich stehe hier
in der briten hochburg am party spot wo
alles leer ist wo alle geschäfte
geschlossen haben wo alle geschäfte
geschlossen bleiben werden zumindest für
die nächsten zwei monate hat man gesagt
und ja die partys verlegen sich hier
mein berichten nach meiner beobachtung
nach an den strand
das heißt wie gesagt die geschäfte sind
geschlossen das gibt er keine option
mehr
also weicht man auf den strand aus die
leute feiern wir mit bluetooth boxen
sie besorgen sich den alkohol am kiosk
es ist aber auch so dass viele bereits
wieder abreisen weil es ihnen dann doch
eben nicht gleich